should tell you more about what she does
momentarily
let me begin with this across the street
from where we gather today
at the k bailey hutchison convention
center
is where the biden administration is
preparing to house
up to 3 000 unaccompanied minors who
cross the border similar sites exist
in carrizo springs texas as well as
midland texas
and that's just as of now the way that
we see
the number of unaccompanied minors
crossing the border there is
every reason for americans to expect the
number and size of those sites
to continue to increase in the coming
days
these sites are a direct result
of president biden's reckless open
border policies
that are causing a surge in border
crossings and cartel activity
the administration has yet to provide
answers that texans deserve
how long will these children be here
what countries
have they come from and what covet
variants
have they been exposed to are they being
tested for covet and if so how is the
administration handling
those who test positive is the federal
government
following cdc quarantine
protocols what happens to these children
if they do test positive for covet and
if they do become ill
who is it that's going to be taking care
of them
the body administration must also answer
for enticing unaccompanied minors
into inhumane conditions
inhumane conditions that expose these
children to
traffickers to abuse and to terror
so far this year more than 11
000 miners have been apprehended
crossing the border into texas
children crossing the border rose 60
from january to february to more than 9
400
in february the number of migrants
crossing the border is
at the highest since march 2019
and is on pace to hit a 20-year high
on monday alone the border patrol took
in
about 280 child migrants in the rio
grande valley sector
america needs to know
how these children some are young
children how they are coming across the
border
and who is it that is helping these
children come across the border
they americans need to know whether or
not these children were harmed or abused
in any way they need to know if these
children were assisted coerced or
threatened
by cartel members or by human
traffickers
were they forced to carry contraband
as they made the trek across mexico to
the american border
all of this is vital information that
can help
america combat these human traffickers
and
prevent other children from being
victimized
americans deserve to know
what the bite administration is doing to
get those answers
and americans deserve to know what the
body administration is doing
to go after these human traffickers
who are preying upon these young
children
the bite administration to get those
answers
should interview every unaccompanied
child coming across the border
they should determine if any child has
been harmed
in any way or victimized by human
traffickers
things like this are already being done
very professionally
and very compassionately for children in
america who are victims of human
trafficking
the children coming across the border
they may share information about human
traffickers or other abusers
this information can help us
root out human trafficking as well as
other criminal activity
now doing these things is the federal
government's
responsibility but once again
it is texas stepping up and doing
what the federal government should be
doing
weeks ago i launched operation lone star
to help secure the border and combat the
smuggling of people and drugs into texas
the texas department of public safety
has deployed
a thousand dps officers agents and
rangers
to support operation lone star
today we are expanding the scope
of operation lone star to crack down
on human trafficking the department of
public safety will work with
the already long-standing governor's
child sex trafficking team as well
as with other organizations and agencies
that have
experience in dealing with human
trafficking and child trafficking
the texas department of public safety
has been and will be
apprehending unaccompanied minors who
cross the border
and when they do they will be seeking
information
about human traffickers as well as other
crimes that may have occurred
today i am directly asking the byte
administration
to allow the texas department of public
safety to
access this facility across the street
at the kay bailey hutcheson center
as well as the other federally run
facilities in texas
to be able to talk to these
unaccompanied minors
we must get to the bottom of the human
trafficking
and put an end to it
the thought of any child
suffering at the hands of human
traffickers
is completely unacceptable we have a
duty to
crack down on this heinous crime and to
prevent more children from being
trafficked and abused
and our mission is especially important
now with a
massive surge in border crossings and
with an
administration in washington that has
not
laid out a clear plan about how to
address
this challenge about human trafficking
or kennedy to be able to address the
massive surge
that's coming across the border so
whether it's
securing the border or fighting human
trafficking
the state of texas will always step up
and fill in the gaps that are left open
by washington
and i want to thank the brave men and
women of the texas department of public
safety who are on the
front lines every single day their
efforts
are vital to work to address
this humanitarian crisis and to keep our
community safe
leading the charge in keeping our
community safe is
director steve mccraw of the texas
department of public safety
governor thank you you know certainly
it's not my
position to comment on policy and as you
know
we abort having to do so but sometimes
uh
unfortunately seemingly compassionate
decisions made our federal government uh
or federal courts for that matter
have resulted in the mass migration of
women and children
to texas and elsewhere and when that
happens it overwhelms border patrol
immediately and of course the governor
launched operation lone star obviously
because the cartels are leveraging those
gaps that have been created by
overwhelming border patrol and putting
them in
the defense in terms of detaining and
all the resources they have to commit
towards
taking care of these children which they
must do which is so vitally important
and it's important that they interview
each of these
and find out what has happened but i can
tell you that the challenge they have in
interviewing these children is this
is they've been threatened by the
cartels when the cartel says
if you talk we're going to kill your
families
they actually mean that and if you're in
mexico or central america from there
they have a great distrust of law
enforcement and concern and they believe
that
when the cartels say that so it's a
challenge to detect those things
and work this but in texas as the
governor pointed out
we cherish children it doesn't matter
where they're from and we have an
obligation to pursue
all crimes against children regardless
of where it happened
and unfortunately many of these children
when they're brought across are preyed
upon
by individuals amongst the smugglers by
the cartel operatives and others
so the challenge for us is in supporting
the border patrol stepping forward and
doing what the state of texas expects is
ensuring that even on the front line you
know our troopers are trained in
interdiction and protection of children
identifying the indicators where
children have been abused when they have
been sexually assaulted
and and people that accompany with them
that are suspicious
i mean in march alone there's sex
offenders that have been convicted and
deported
were captured with among illegal aliens
coming across family units and
unaccompanied children it's important
that we identify those things pursue
those things and ensure there's no
crimes
what's often not mentioned we recognize
that the gaps create that
methamphetamine cocaine heroin fentanyl
if you've got a drug problem in the u.s
it's coming through the border
we recognize that and they're exploiting
children for that purpose
the other part what people don't realize
is there's there's another these
this category will call for just for
this purposes we'll call
a high-value migrant and unfortunately
those that have been involved
and there's some behind me that are
involved in sex trafficking
investigations
what happens is young women from central
america and mexico are lured
to texas on the promise of a service
industry job or a nanny
or some other job and when they come
here to the united states and there's a
case that was just discussing
and thank you for what you do in helping
us with our investigations
there's this the case that it would
stain your stole if you saw what would
happen what people will do to mankind at
our most precious the children is just
amazing it's just sickening
and what they would do is promise these
jobs they get them here they debrief
them fully to know where their families
are how can they get contact because if
they escape
they can compel them back by threatening
their families
and it's happened and they'll bring them
over as young as 13 years old
and after they debrief them they'll gang
rape and then they'll compel into
prostitution
i don't care if it's 15 minutes for 45
some of the most brutal things you've
seen done to children
it happened in the u.s and right now
we're concerned about i know the
governor's concerned about it i know
that
andrea sparks are concerned about others
that care about children from around the
world
as victims that's a we this is an
opportunity for the sex
industry to exploit it certainly the
cartels benefit
when these gaps occur when this mass
migration happens
they benefit but so does the gangs that
support them on
both sides of the border and so does the
sex trafficking industry
trying to you know you know feed this
unending demand
for trafficking and the more high value
of trafficking is the young
children so it's clearly a high priority
department i know we
governor talked about it we discussed it
yesterday that the department of public
safety
i mean he's made it clear the state
legislatures made it clear
is that it's everybody's job is human
trafficking particularly sex trafficking
and
when i say everybody it means a texas
state trooper needs to be an expert in
it
a special agent a dps special agent
needs to be an expert at it
so does our intelligence analyst and so
does texas rangers and we employ
all of those resources to try to address
this this hines
crime uh and of course and consistent
with operation lone star
governor we've stood up the state this
is the north texas region and we're
prepared to
to do interviews to look for any clues
or any opportunities to
to pursue anyone that would would
violate
any of these children or any other
children and certainly engage in sex
trafficking so thank you governor thank
you and it's my expectation
that the body administration will allow
you and your team
into this convention center to visit
with the children
who they are putting into that
convention center later on today
so next i want to introduce andrea
sparks and
i want to tell you about her so you can
understand
the perspective that she speaks from
andrea is the director of the governor's
child sex trafficking team where she's
been for about four years
the team promotes policies to prevent
child sexual exploitation
and to bring exploiters to justice
andrea's team
has become a national leader in efforts
to prevent child exploitation and to
support the criminal justice system
in holding exploiters accountable after
graduating from the university of texas
school of law
she served as a staff attorney at the
texas supreme court
after that she went on to represent both
children and families
in child protection cases before coming
to the governor's office
she served as the executive director of
the texas regional office
for the national center for missing and
exploited children
andrea sparks thank you governor thank
you for assembling us here today to talk
about this very
very critical issue we are very
concerned at the child sex trafficking
team
about the youth and the children who are
coming across the border
they are in a perfect storm of
vulnerability
we've heard stories that kids as young
as six
are crossing the border alone and they
are scared they are confused and they
are
very likely to end up in the hands of an
exploiter
from what we know about human
trafficking and how it works
our team has been at work for almost
five years now governor
to build the model the texas model for
commercially sexually exploited youth
and we have a system in place that can
help any
child every child who is identified as a
victim of exploitation
so we work every day and are committed
to preventing
identifying and addressing child
exploitation
whether that comes in the form of a
pimp or a gang or a family a family
member unfortunately that happens
and even international cartels and we do
this
on a daily basis with our partners that
we provide
support to and and partner with on a
daily basis at the children's advocacy
centers
and at many other child serving agencies
across the state of texas
we do that so that these kids get the
safety
that they need and deserve and the
services and supports they need to not
only heal from their trafficking
experience
but in order to thrive as a person as a
human being
and so with us today is one of those
service providers and i'm going to let
her talk to you all in a minute we do
have specially trained
advocates and case managers like
christie
all over the state of texas in over 130
counties
who can provide crisis intervention
long-term case management and that
trauma-informed care
and supportive relationship that these
kids need especially
if they're being exploited and we stand
ready
governor and and director mccraw to work
with you as always
to make sure that every child in texas
is protected
from exploitation thank you very much
and as you mentioned
one of your partners is an organization
the name of which is traffic 911
and from that organization we have with
us here today christy lopez
thank you for having us governor i am an
advocate with traffic 9-1-1
and it is our pleasure to partner with
the governor's office to ensure that any
and all
exploited children and youth in north
texas have access to services
are able to receive trauma-informed care
and that are able to connect with the
safe and healthy relationships that they
need
to heal and thrive in a trabajadora con
traffic 911
thank you very much we'll take a few
questions
to be clear every year that i have been
governor
we have been engaged in border surges
exactly like what we're doing now
from the first session that i was
governor the state legislature
appropriated almost a billion dollars
for every biennium
from the beginning until now so that we
do have the resources to deploy
not only the texas department of public
safety but also the national guard
and so for this entire time moving in
different numbers
but also maintaining a constant presence
both the texas department of public
safety and the national guard
have been involved there is something
different
this time and far more prolifically than
in the past
quite often in the past there has been a
large number of single adults
or family units coming across the border
what we're seeing now is far more
prolific numbers
in unaccompanied children making their
way to locations like here in dallas or
midland or other parts in the state of
texas
and as the director mccraw pointed out
his team has been involved in the past
in dealing with the human trafficking
component about this
but because of the large number of
children already
and because it is clear what is about to
happen in the coming weeks and months
and that is the number of children you
see have come across the border already
is going to be a tiny fraction of what
we will see in the coming months
we're trying to get ahead of this as
much as possible and engage a team like
this
that said let me be very clear about
this and that is
texas is willing to step up and help out
but this is
the biden's administration
responsibility in part
immigration is always a federal
responsibility in part
it's the policies that have been adopted
by the administration that have
escalated the number of children coming
across the border where the body
administration has made it clear
that if you are an unaccompanied child
you will be allowed to come into the
united states
that means that we need to engage more
now than ever before
with regard to the human trafficking
component that said again to be clear
my expectation is today
the bond administration will step up and
do its job
to address the human trafficking
component about this
if they fail to do so for one they
should answer to
americans why they are failing these
children
in this human trafficking enterprise but
also if they fail to do so
we will use every tool that we have
available to us
to fully address this challenge
[Music]
it's not like these children are
newcomers
who found themselves in it they are
children who
have been held in inhumane uh
circumstances and abiding administration
is trying to make sure that
the image of america doesn't uh is not
followed doesn't become this bad image
or see what they are doing to children
so giving them over to fema and hhs
is basically an institution of the
american federal government that's going
to take care of them
but they will still be within the uh the
confines
of american government of our government
are you politicizing this issue or
why do you think that the inhumane
matter should be used
these children should suffer if they are
victims of child trafficking
if that is what is being done to help
them why are you
against what is right why are you making
america
before the international community
several things in response
as i've made clear texas
as a state coming out of our own state
budget
have been very aggressive in dealing
with the challenges coming across the
border
during the entirety of my governorship
and then preceding
my governorship texans should not have
to be coming out of
texas taxpayer pocket books to do the
federal government's job
during the course of our response
director mcgraw and his staff
with the texas department of public
safety and others
have been engaged in this process of
trying to root out
the human trafficking element but let's
clarify something that you said that i
disagree with
the blind administration opened the
floodgates to
any child who wants to come across a
border is going to be able to come
across the border and i know from what's
going on on the ground
they are completely ill-prepared for
this
one easy example and that is when
the amount of children coming across the
border turned out to be far more than
what they expected
they had no clue where to send those
children
on what was it saturday night
this past saturday night there was an
email
sent from federal health and human
services
to my staff at 9 30 pm that i did not
get until about
10 pm on saturday night where
federal health and human services they
were scrambling
to try to find some location where to
send those children
and they eventually wound up deciding
over the night
those children would be going to midland
texas without knowing whether or not
there's
running water or workable sewage or what
the conditions may be
there's they were scrambling talking to
other locations around the state of
texas trying to find a location
for the children who were coming to
dallas texas the biden administration is
completely not prepared
for the number of children coming across
this border and
the worst thing about it however and
this is maybe the most important thing i
could tell america right now
what the body administration is doing by
allowing any child who wants to come
across the border to come here
it means that he is going to subject
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of children
to the horrific trauma maybe assault
and human trafficking that these
children have to go through
as they make that trek through the
border i urge
president biden do not traumatize
these children by enticing them to make
this trek
president you have the ability to put an
end to this
and ensure the safety of these children
by not enticing them
into that very dangerous trek
that you made today governor the first
point that you made today was about
the potential spread of the coronavirus
and that these unaccompanied children
may add to that spread there are people
out there governor respectfully that
will say you
dropped the mass mandate last week you
lifted all coronavirus
restrictions to those who say you aren't
the right person right now to be
speaking about the potential
additional spread of the coronavirus
what would you say to them
when we make decisions about
opening up which by the way when i made
my announcement
texas was already open up 75
so we went from 75 percent to 100
percent
and that decision was based upon several
different data points
it was based upon the reduction in the
positivity rate which
the last i saw was yesterday it dropped
down to six percent for
two days in a row uh it was based on the
dramatic reduction in hospitalizations
uh
which is the lowest in six months the
positivity rate is the lowest in almost
10 months and the vaccines
have just continued to increase very
importantly
we look at those who are most in danger
of either
losing their life or being hospitalized
because of exposure
exposure to covet and those are people
who are age
65 and older and well over
55 percent of the people who fall into
that
most vulnerable population for covet
have received a vaccine shot
my point is this decisions were based
upon metrics as they existed at that
time
those metrics are changing not by the
positivity rate of the
people who are coming across the border
but by the number of people coming
across the border
who have coveted and who may be bringing
variants in the key point that i wanted
to make about covid
was really the variant know this
people coming across the border that for
one they're coming through mexico which
is considered to be one of the hottest
hot spots for covet in the world
but how many of these kids are coming
from brazil
how many are coming from central america
that may have exposure to
the variant in brazil we know
others are coming from other continents
across the entire globe
there are all these other variants my
point is this
the byte administration has a
responsibility
to work collaboratively with state
health
services so that the state will be able
to respond
the bite administration has done nothing
to work with state health services
to inform state health services who are
these kids
where they coming from what exposure
they may have we
as a state are incapable of responding
to this potential cova challenge because
of the biden's administration's
refusal to provide us the information we
need
to be able to respond
[Music]
to test
administration offered the state funding
to give to fema to do testing
the f in fema stands for federal
the federal government has the full
capability
of giving money and cova test
to fema without even having to talk to
the governor about it
they did not need my permission to get
that done as was proven by the fact
that they have done it since my refusal
to participate in it all they wanted to
do
that was a political game by the by
administration where they wanted to
try to have texas assist them
in their illegal immigration program
which we refuse to do
the federal government has the money
they have the federal agencies whether
it be fema
or federal health and human services or
ice
where these cess can be run to be clear
about this if the
administration is doing it correctly i'm
going to explain the process
first when a person comes across the
border they first encounter typically
a border patrol officer that border
patrol officer
after the detention they have to turn
them over to ice
and it should be ice when they first go
into a holding
situation it should be ice that performs
the test
that performs the quara team the medical
assessment
and that is the responsibility of the
federal government
not the state government
[Music]
we'll get you that here than you got
sure and are you maybe talking about the
flora's decision or something like that
so here's the deal whatever court order
it was
there are issues with regard to
allowing children in but
that does not answer the biden
administration's
failure to fully address the children
who are coming in
for one they do have a responsibility in
the time of a worldwide pandemic
to make the covet assess but but more
importantly what we're really here to
talk about is not that
what we're really here to talk about is
we do have the strategies
and the capabilities of addressing the
human trafficking component
that these children are going through
and we are demanding
that the biden administration step up
and address
the human trafficking component of all
these children coming here
yes yes
where are you specifically as it relates
to
reversing ercot's overcharges
do you agree with the state senate bill
and the lieutenant governor as far as
reversing it
or do you agree with the house speaker
who opposes this
and secondly can you explain why you
asked for the guc
chair's resignation and didn't have
anything to do with the comments he made
to invest
so on on the first question i've already
made multiple comments about that
and i'll just leave those comments you
can pull them up with regard to the
second question
listen we want to make sure
that we are going to show the vision to
our fellow texans that we are
charting a new and fresh course for the
the public utilities commission
and the action that i made is one of
many steps
that will be taken to achieve those
goals thank you all very much
you